alright hey guys i'm ryan right guys
Monaco and yeah I just realized I'm
always [ __ ] when I'm around you is
that's so ironic which brings me to the
fact that we're gonna watch the trailer
for the drop I don't know anything about
the drop I don't know no idea we watch
so I think it links though and I would
also like to say I just got these jeans
out of the washer and dryer and they
feel a lot tighter so I said tyranny
yeah not after they're done with you
there was a compliment that was a great
race Ally yes dude we're about to watch
James Gandolfini's in this okay yeah no
can take a look at the side whose name
is on it
notice my name
I was respected I was filled
where I wanted to place people set up
that made sucked it it's been over for
why now those are all good get a
neighborhood change go ahead over drop
which oh your money in the bag
do you know what you doing do you know
whose money it jacket everyone knows it
was that would mean we were in are they
are not just gonna go away
people like me come along look at you
stay away from it
paid or some desperate so that we can to
clean up place you don't see anything I
just in the barn
seriously your committee you can't come
back from
let me take him
that was pretty [ __ ] cool yeah yeah I
uh I dig movies like that a lot
hey [ __ ] New Yorkers [ __ ] watch man
every time you walk out out of New York
movie you're always like y'all bought at
the drop yeah that's a horrible New York
accent okay yo you're talking to me oh
you dumb son of a [ __ ] show that's my
coffee and drop it off ya Jewish New
Yorker that's awesome that's awesome
first off the the number one thing I'm
like noticing from this is the acting
was really good like I love Tom Hardy
he's one of the best actors around right
now Tom Hardy famous for his role in
that movie that I saw yes I saw that
dude yes we know a lot about movies
James Gandolfini and we all have miss
James Guthrie me and it is it's kind of
cool to see him like cuz you know he has
passed away for a while why is your mom
doing a different voice yes dry bone now
but James Gandolfini a man everyone
knows like he was Grand the Sopranos but
what always sucks has been like if an
actor does pass the way they don't get
to go out with a bang they'll get like
that Heath Ledger yeah this looks like
no man he was the [ __ ] and people are
gonna remember that [ __ ] out of that
yeah Tom Hardy's really cool and he was
like you just brought everything to that
role that's all right it doesn't seem
like you're watching Tony Soprano again
it just seems like you're watching a
different guy like audiences really get
to see this range that's it that's a
true actor you know just not being able
to do more characters you know having a
long range anymore so that's awesome I
think this is great that he even
yeah that would suck you know if they
worked so hard at this movie and they
couldn't finish it though mm-hmm I
totally agree
[ __ ] is on your phone and the other
thing I really like about this I mean
the fact that it's based on a lot of
movie adaptations that I really do like
all those movies like gone baby gone
Mystic River Shutter Island to name a
few
those are the only ones I know right
myself those are all [ __ ] fantastic
movies and this looks like it's gonna be
another great crime addition so yeah I
give it an a dude what are you doing
puppy she's a new cast member we thought
we'd bring more of a family vibe I'm
going to take New York anyway guys
thanks for recommending that trailer if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the reel rejects we have a
lot of crap on there and you can
subscribe to Sally's channel which
doesn't have as much crap but there's
still good crap on there great crowd
it's no it's not like you can literally
smell it through the computer time is
not a crap hey you know we should do
know that we talked about crap what we
should do shoutouts okay shoutouts are
[ __ ] Joey Jean Ryan I'm happy for you do
that you're with Veronica now you both
are a great couple I mean Ryan you're
funny and hilarious yeah and a legend on
your channel thank you
listen can I get a shout out from all
from you all from Dublin Dublin we now
say story in Dublin which means hello in
Dublin Oh read more because we haven't
read enough from this guy oh I scroll
down to find a D come on Oh
so YouTube [ __ ] up your comment dami
YouTube and it's not a question it's a
it's a statement right there
y'all need to learn proper grammar on
the YouTube because nothing you do a
southern accent what do your mom switch
in a random act I don't know alright
well Joe King you're a dumb son of a
[ __ ] hmm no I love you Joey King you
stay classy San G marianm Alonso wait
Ryan so you're half Filipino wow I'm
Filipino please give the Philippines a
shout-out thanks
Marlon Milazzo I'm not even gonna
mention your name Marlon Alonzo I'm
gonna give the shout out to all of the
Filipinos in the Philippines this dick
talking [ __ ] lovin smoking weed and
[ __ ] is representing all you
guys right now you should do karaoke
with us sometime I would love to do
karaoke yeah I used to do it with improv
kids and they kicked out nice and we
should uh we should go to jolly beam
together it's a Filipino restaurant but
they serve burgers out okay yeah and
then we should go watch the Manny
Pacquiao fight uh you don't know who
Manny Pacquiao's you know look I'm taken
and whenever I talk to you you have this
habit of looking down if you
lips which makes me think from a book I
read that you are so into me right no I
did and I'm trying to tell you Sally
back the [ __ ] up I know a Filipino I
know I'm Filipino how's our slaw despot
you said big so yeah Dane Leslie hey man
love your channel could I maybe have a
shout-out maybe maybe maybe oh can you
dude unit sucks about you we read two
really good comments and you write this
miniature comment and what are we
supposed to work off of exactly are we
supposed to be funny about here Leslie
what are you Dane Leslie are you a guy
with a girl's name hey we actually could
get some material how often we made fun
of let's lean whatever guy from the
[ __ ] airplanes movie what yeah you
know yeah yeah yeah call me Shirley
uh-huh yeah that one that one you know
yeah damn Leslie that's who you are
there we go we gave you a [ __ ] shadow
we did it we made it work you give us
much so think our [ __ ] ass